olá meu nome é maria alice e eu já vim
aqui apresentar para vocês sobre um tema
que eu acho que todo mundo deveria saber
um pouquinho que é efeito do
desmatamento ambiental no planeta o que
vem a ser desmatamento desmatamento é um
problema global colocar ameaça aos
recursos naturais
o meio ambiente que teve equilíbrio
ecológico do planeta mas de energia
solar igual - matamento vocês devem
estar perguntando como assim mais
energia solar igualmente desmatamento é
assim a energia solar é tem essas placas
que embaixo delas em um gerador e quando
os raios solares e batem aqui é esses
raios não aqui pra baixo e um gerador
dos sinais e energia também tem a
energia é essa a base do petróleo carvão
essas coisas mas o eu vou falar pra
vocês que a energia do carvão à base de
carvão não é muito boa porque para fazer
o carvão a gente tem que cortar as
árvores e essas coisas conseqüência do
desmatamento
algumas cidades ainda estão assim mas a
metade de outras está assim porque nós
estamos desmatando muito o meio ambiente
é é isso pode causar é muito
desmatamento conscientização ecológica o
homem precisa ter concentração ecológica
do que ele está fazendo
como é ele não pode cortar árvores de
lugares proibidos e árvores proibidas
primeiro tempo pedir autorização do
governo para poder cortar as árvores e
falar o lugar aqui vai ter que cortar e
sempre é bom você verificar o imóvel que
você está comprando pra poder ver se é
com madeira ilegal o legal
o homem ele não queimadas às vezes a
pessoa tá fumando jogar bituca de
cigarro é pela janela do carro
isso pode causar uma queimada é também
às vezes o homem joga fogo só pra é
destruir o meio ambiente e às vezes por
causa de agrícola mas o sol não está
preparado para isso
matam seres vivos as queimadas estão
matando muitos seres vivos e isso pode
prejudicar muito o nosso planeta
se todo mundo fizer um pouquinho teremos
um planeta melhor é todo mundo ajudar é
não consumir muito papel vez tratos
online e se esse tipo de coisas podemos
ser um planeta muito melhor do que temos
agora
todos nós temos uma única casa ea nossa
casa eo planeta terra se contínuo se
continuarmos hoje destruindo ele podemos
perdê lo
obrigada